it's michelle of lab muffin beauty science
here chemistry phd cosmetic chemist and big
fan of asian skin care today i'm going to be
talking about my favorite heimish products
heimish is a korean brand that's best known for
their cleansing balm it has a cult following and
obviously i'll be talking about that but they have
a lot of other really interesting products too
this video is sponsored by stylekorean
an online korean beauty store that
stocks heimish along with tons of other brands
like and subscribe and click the nerdification
bell so you know when new videos go up
i'm going to start with the heimish all
clean balm this is heimish's most popular product
and lots of people have this as their all-time
favorite cleansing balm and for good reason i've
been using this for years i don't think i've
ever reviewed it though and i should really do a
video on my favorite cleansing balms but this one
is very high up there in case you didn't already
know cleansing balms are great for quickly getting
makeup and waterproof sunscreen off your face
really fast i talked about this before in my
cleansing myths video but you don't actually need
to use an oil-based cleanser to remove makeup and
sunscreen a lot of the time regular cleansers
will work fine and you can even remove them with
microfiber cloths and plain water but a lot
of people including me really like using oil
based cleansers for that because it feels really
effortless and the oil massage is really relaxing
so how you use these you scoop out a
small amount of the cleansing balm then
you massage it over your dry dirty face
at the start of your cleansing routine
the solid balm will melt on your skin as you
rub and it turns into an oil then you rinse it
off with warm water i personally rub the balm on
before i get into the shower and then i rinse it
off in the shower and you'll see the water go
milky as it emulsifies and the oil droplets go
into the water you can follow up with a regular
cleanser like a foaming cleanser which i do
if i'm wearing makeup or if you think your
skin is clean enough you can just leave it
which is what i do if i didn't leave the house
and i didn't wear sunscreen or makeup that day
this balm is a really good cleansing
balm that works really well to
get rid of waterproof makeup including
mascara and it rinses off really cleanly
some cleansing balms will leave a bit of oil
on your face and depending on the product you
can either leave this on your face or you might
prefer to get it off with a follow-up cleanser
i've personally found that it really depends
on which balm i'm using whether or not i break
out with that extra oil but with this one
you don't have a layer left behind so you
don't need to worry about it this is just one of
the more affordable cleansing balms that works
really well it's slightly scented it has this
flip top lid that makes it really easy to get into
it has a little spot for storing your spatula if
you're a neat person who's not into digging out
the product with your fingers or just like
smashing the spatula in there for storage
this product does have polyethylene in it i'll
talk more about it in a future video because it's
a bit of a complicated topic but very briefly
this has a form of polyethylene in it but there
are lots of different types of polyethylene
and the type in cleansing balms is probably
somewhat biodegradable it's a less solid form
than microbeads so the environmental impacts
are quite different the amount in it is also
really small compared to the other microplastics
you generally produce in the rest of your life
so while i'd like it if brands replaced it with
more degradable ingredients it isn't
really a big deal breaker for me
i tried a bunch of heimish's cleansers
and these two are my favorites
this is the ph 5.5 all clean green foam i really
like that this has a low skin friendly ph of 5.5
because a lot of asian cleansers tend to have
really high ph's high ph will disrupt your
skin a bit more than a lower ph that matches your
skin's ph this foams nicely it cleanses nicely and
it doesn't leave my skin feeling tight afterwards
it is fragrance free and it smells a bit plasticky
as i've mentioned before i do prefer a mild
fragrance in my cleansers to not have that smell
this is just very functional i think
it's a great option i personally find
it a bit boring but for a lot
of people no frills is exactly
what you want in a cleanser and if
that's you i highly recommend this
there's also the all clean white clay foam
i actually like this a bit more than the
other one this is a foaming cleanser that has two
types of clay in it which is bentonite and kaolin
so it soaks up oil as you clean it's sort of like
a way of getting the benefits of a clay mask while
you're cleansing so i love lazy products this
does have a high ph it's around eight or nine
but this is probably the nicest feeling high ph
cleanser i've ever tried it's soap based but the
soap's been mixed with other non-soap surfactants
which should reduce the soap disrupting your skin
this also has glycerin in it which stops your skin
from getting too dehydrated while cleansing i've
talked about how formulations can make surfactants
work gently in my cleansing myths video as well
i didn't find this drying or tight but i did try
it during an australian summer which is pretty
humid and i have oily skin i did try a couple
of other high ph soap based cleansers over the
last few months and they haven't worked as well
as this so i do think this is actually gentler
and i was actually quite surprised it didn't
feel tight even though there is that clay in it
this also has hydrolyzed silk and hyaluronic acid
which would help keep your skin hydrated as well
it has a light scent which comes from essential
oils and so i'd recommend this for people with
oily skin maybe go for the other one if you
have dry skin or you're sensitive to fragrance
moving on to moisturizers heimish have a whole
bunch of really nice moisturizers and these
are my favorites one thing i love about
asian skincare is that there are a lot
of gel moisturizers available that are really
good for oily dehydration prone skin and just
hot weather in general standard moisturizers are
usually creams or lotions that are oil in water
emulsions and these use traditional emulsifiers
to keep all droplets suspended in the product
these traditional emulsifiers can sometimes
feel pretty heavy with a gel cream the oil
droplets get suspended using a network of
special polymers and this ends up feeling
a lot lighter on your skin gel creams are a
lot more popular in asia there aren't a ton
of gel cream options available at a lower price
point in australia so i was really excited to try
the watermelon moisture soothing gel cream this
is fantastic it used to be called the moisture
surge gel cream and it's very similar to the
clinique version this has a very lightweight
texture but it's really hydrating there's lots
of glycerin in it and it leaves behind a satiny
hydrated looking finish on my skin it doesn't
pill i'm actually wearing it now under my makeup
it's fragrance free and the smell is not
very offensive for a fragrance-free product
i also really like the all clean vitamin blemish
spot clear cream this is a slightly heavier cream
it's more moisturizing but again it's really
hydrating with lots of glycerin it feels really
cooling when you put it on your skin and i think i
could still probably use it as a heavier day cream
this has a light scent and it has five percent
niacinamide and vitamin c which comes from
kakadu plum extract it's actually approved as a
functional cosmetic in korea for brightening and
anti-wrinkle claims and i believe that's because
it contains two to five percent niacinamide and
0.04% adenosine but it does also have clinical
testing on the box which you can see on this graph
and that shows that it has
a modest decrease in pigment
and you can also see some before
and afters on the heimish website
the box also shows the irritation
testing and i think this is just
a really nice moisturizer i love that you can get
a high percentage of niacinamide in one product
which means you can sort of spend
your serums on other ingredients
moving on to the marine care cream toner this is a
newer sort of product for me it's a toner that has
a lot of oil in it but it's very watery as you can
see but it moisturizes a lot more like a lotion
this product is very similar to the
laneige cream skin which i also love
they both have very similar top line
moisturizing ingredients which are
butylene glycol and glycerin as humectants as
well as meadowfoam seed oil as the oil component
it's also approved as a functional cosmetic
for brightening and anti-wrinkle in korea
which i'm guessing means that the niacinamide
in this is between two and five percent
and the adenosine is at 0.04% it also has marine
extracts in it and according to the packaging it's
in liposomal form which means they're bundled up
in little packets which supposedly should deliver
better into your skin this also has a very mild
scent whereas the laneige is fragrance free but
on my skin the moisturizing effect
is pretty much the same for both
so i guess your choice would depend on whether you
want more actives and how you feel about fragrance
i also tried the marine care eye cream i usually
don't use eye creams because i wear contact lenses
at night and if any product gets into my eyes
it is a massive pain i have to go through the
whole contact lens removal and reinsertion process
but i gave this one a go because it has a thicker
texture and so i figured it probably wouldn't
travel as much and i was right this does hydrate
my under eye area pretty nicely without traveling
into my eyes this also has that niacinamide
and adenosine combo that makes it a functional
cosmetic it also has marine extracts and peptides
again it has that liposomal technology which
should deliver that deeper into your skin this
does have a moderate scent but because you don't
use very much product it's not super noticeable
it comes with a metal de-puffing massage stick
and this is quite soothing i found myself using
it during the day when i was in front of the
computer and my eyes were getting a bit tired
i prefer applying this cream by pressing it
in with my fingers because the texture is a
bit thick and so it's a bit difficult to spread
with the stick but massaging it in with the cool
stick afterwards is really nice i don't think you
necessarily need a separate eye cream unless you
have the same problem as me where your face likes
products that slide around but your eyes don't
and i guess i'm just not really an eye cream
connoisseur because i haven't tried that many
but i did find myself really enjoying this i found
myself reaching for it a lot more than i expected
my final pick from the heimish range of the
products i tried is the black tea mask pack
this has a really puree fluffy sorbet sort
of texture it is moderately strongly scented
and it's quite a floral scent to use it you apply
it for five to ten minutes and then you wash it
off i wiped it off with a damp cloth or cotton
pad and i've heard that some people leave this
on overnight i wasn't expecting a lot from this
product because you are only meant to use it for
five to ten minutes but i was really impressed
by how hydrating it was in such a short amount
of time the effect this had was kind of like a
sheet mask without being a sheet mask i think
i've mentioned before how i don't really like
sheet masks because they're kind of fussy to me
i know a lot of people like to relax with a sheet
mask on but i find that i don't really relax which
i know sounds kind of bad but i like to do things
while i relax like i like to read or crochet
and i don't like the distraction of the feeling of
the sheet mask sliding down a layer of this feels
just like moisturizer and i found that this gave
me a lot of those hydrating skin smoothing effects
that sheet masks tend to give i haven't used a
lot of masks recently because they are just to me
a lot of effort but this is like a really low
effort mask that still delivers a lot of benefits
so those are my favorite heimish products so far
all the links to buy are in the description
and they're currently on sale at stylekorean
let me know if you've tried any of these
products before and what you thought of them
i've also got some more reviews of asian skincare
products in the description you can follow me on
instagram tiktok check out my blog and see
you next time for more nerdy beauty talk